tout de suite c'est drôle de campagne
éclair ce sera sans doute la plus courte
qu'on est connu pour un président
sortant depuis celle de françois
mitterrand en 1988 alors on a eu une
lettre aux français un message vidéo
posté sur les réseaux sociaux est
aujourd'hui des premiers déplacements
pour emmanuel macron qui se transforme
en candidat quels sont ses plans retour
sur une première journée de campagne
éclair par marion delpech
une entrée par l'arrière du bâtiment
pour une première venue à son qg malgré
ce contexte international et la guerre
en ukraine l'heure est désormais à la
campagne présidentielle pour emmanuel
macron venu motiver ses troupes
le président a ensuite esquissé les
contours de son projet en présence
d'edouard philippe hubert falco
christian estrosi ou encore renaud
muselier ses soutiens chargé de porter
son projet pour la france une campagne
électorale et les jouets de ce qu'on a
dépouillé le dernier bulletin de vote il
nous a demandé d'être sérieux déterminer
sur le terrain de la dé convaincre de
faire en sorte que les gens aient eu via
nouveautés et 2 votre peau emmanuel
macron on doit avoir un président qui
expérimentent et on le voit dans la
cadre de la crise sur le domaine
international sur le domaine européen on
voit bien que les positions qui ont été
prises en son temps par le président de
la république a été avant gardiste quand
même il a bien sûr une priorité absolue
qui est de gérer la guerre avec
la russie entre la russie et l'ukraine
vous connaissez sa place qui est celle
de président en exercice de l'union
européenne
et chaque fois qu'il le pourra il ira à
la rencontre des français pour présenter
son projet ce lundi soir emmanuel macron
se rendra chez son ami et soutien karl
olive à poissy pour son premier
déplacement officiel de candidat avant
de participer à l'émission face aux
français sur elle si oui candidats
seront interrogés par plusieurs
françaises avant la journée
internationale des droits des femmes le
8 mars
comment aimer les maquereaux on va gérer
cette campagne éclair cette campagne
extrêmement courte comment vont réagir
ses rivaux et notamment eric zemmour ou
marine le pen on en parle ce soir avec
nos invités bérengère bonté bonsoir vous
êtes journaliste auteur d'une récente
biographie d'edouard philippe lesueur
aux éditions de l'archipel j'arrive
camus bonsoir vous êtes politologue co
directeur de l'observatoire des
radicalités politique à la fondation
jean jaurès merci de nous avoir rejoints
chaque oeil aussi alexandre des vecchio
sûr vous êtes rédacteur en chef du
figaro vox et des pages et spire esprits
libres pardon du figaro magazine et puis
bon jour aussi par écran interposé à
jean-philippe dubrulle directeur
d'études à l'ifop qui nous rejoint pour
la première partie de cette émission je
sais que vous devez partir assez vite
pour qu'on vous interrogera à ses torts
et puis bien sûr j'accueille notre
chroniqueuse laetitia krupa qui restera
bien évidemment à mes côtés tout au long
de l'émission pour commencer ce débat
j'ai envie de faire un rapide tour de
table et de vous demander de répondre
brièvement à cette question tous les
sondages donnent emmanuel macron archi
favori au premier tour comme au second
est ce que les jeux sont déjà faits
alexandre de wikio
je dirais oui et je pense que emmanuel
macron est le grand favori de cette
élection et que ce qui se joue c'est la
recomposition politique qui avait
d'ailleurs été entamée par emmanuel
macron ya cinq ans plus tôt à gauche
avec la disparition du parti socialiste
qui s'est confirmée aujourd'hui c'est
plutôt la recomposition de la droite qui
en train de se jouer entre valérie
pécresse avec une possible résurrection
de l air mais qui paraît aujourd'hui
compliquée où eric zemmour et marine le
pen qui va l'emporter et pour pour
quelle droite qu'elle va être cette
cette nouvelle droite dans un contexte
de mondialisation où il ya une
recomposition général des forces
politiques est précisément le clivage
droite gauche ou tout à fait ce que
celui qu'il était il ya quelques années
alexandre s'intéresse déjà au coup
d'après mais en général on sait que les
jeux sont faits je pense aussi que on
voit pas bien ce qui pourrait contrarier
une réélection de d'emmanuel macro moi
je crois pour pour essayer de compléter
ce qui a été dit que ce qui se joue
aussi c'est la cie la paix du
quinquennat et que si emmanuel macron ne
ne s'impose pas un véritable débat où un
début de débat avec tout le contexte
international et qu'on connaît il le
paiera et la france le père a assez cher
je pense et notamment socialement dans
un an deux ans
n'oublions pas les gilles et jo
n'oublions pas tout ce qui s'est passé
et même si la situation internationale
fij un peu le la situation la suite va
dépendre
jamais
le match et peut-être plier je me dis un
petit peu la chose en disant que la
participation serait absolument
essentiel mais le match est
effectivement assez plier sauf que et
cela vient d'être dit très justement la
cocotte-minute est toujours en
ébullition et que les années qui
viennent faute non seulement d'un
véritable débat puisque la campagne va
être hyper courte mais il sans doute une
certaine remise en question sinon delà
de ce qu'il faut faire du moins de la
façon de le de le faire savoir il le dit
on va être un enjeu absolument essentiel
et j'ai une petite question alors pour
la cocotte minute juste parce qu'en fait
c'est tous les observateurs sont
pratiquement unanimes sur ce chaos
social qui pourrait trouver une fois qu
emmanuel macron passerait parce qu'on
aurait peut-être escamoté cette élection
mais comment vous mesurer cette cocotte
minute comment vous la mesure et quels
sont les capteurs qui permettent de dire
oui attention la colère sociale et à tel
niveau que si emmanuel macron passe moi
je l'entends ce discours mais il faudra
je pense
le taux d'abstention il faut rappeler
que déjà emmanuel macron avait été mal
est mal élu avec un taux d'abstention
est vote blanc record au second tour et
surtout et surtout aux législatives où
il y avait moins de 50% de participation
je crois que c'était historique donc le
taux d'abstention dira beaucoup et il ya
deux scénarios soit ce qu'on peut
appeler une forme de sécession de la
plèbe avec des gens qui est la plèbe je
parle au sens commun du terme à ça pas
de c'est pas péjoratif toutes ces
catégories qui ne sont pas représentées
qui se disent finalement on va
s'organiser nous même c'est pas terrible
non plus passer un scénario d'archipel
isation de la franche où la révolte de
ces personnes là ce qui était déjà
arrivé il ya cinq ans le lait gilet
jaune et avait été une sorte de retour
du refoulé le problème existe on ne peut
pas dire une hausse tant l'abstention
c'est l'absence y est on y est le
baromètre de la colère et si vous
aboutissez effectivement à une situation
oui de quasi s'échappe chez %
d'abstention 2017 c'était déjà énorme ce
sera mon avis il sans doute au moins
égal si vous aboutissez une situation de
quasi cession d'une partie de
l'électorat majoritairement composés
effectivement de jean d'extraction de
populaire s'est tassée c'est assez
compliqué de dérouler votre bourgogne
comme si de rien n'était et juste
n'oublions pas le mouv même s'il faut
toujours être prudent sur la convergence
des mouvements mais le mouvement
antivaccin et toute la colère qui est
qui et qui qu'on a vu poindre
il ya eu clairement cherche à aller au
delà de gens qui étaient
fondamentalement anti vaccins on l'a
beaucoup observé ils sont toujours là
avant de passer la la la la la parole à
jean philippe du brûlé coûté en tout cas
la réponse du principal intéressé
emmanuel macron quand on lui demande si
le match est plié c'était dans un
une vidéo concoctée par ses services son
équipe de campagne posté vendredi sur
les réseaux sociaux écouter ta réponse
non pas du tout alors ça détrompez-vous
complètement nous sommes un peuple très
politique les françaises et les français
sont tous
et ils ne donnent pas leur confiance
comme ça et donc si h/f secondes on
considère que la confiance est acquise
mais on n'a pas à se remettre en cause
et à aller la chercher la solliciter à
ce moment là en père
jean-philippe dubrulle qu'est-ce qui
peut encore bouger dans les électorats
c'est vrai qu'à voir la situation la
cote des manuels mâcon dans les
différentes intentions de vote on a une
situation inédite d'un président sortant
qui se retrouvent à 30% des intentions
de vote qui a pris cinq fois en une
semaine à la faveur de de la crise en
ukraine et en russie c'est du jamais vu
qu'est-ce qui pourrait stopper emmanuel
macron à date on le voit je rejoindrai
les personnes en plateau sur ce
diagnostic là on ne voit pas grand chose
qui pourrait si c'est une catastrophe
totalement imprévue je repense à 2017 l
affaire fillon a quelque chose qui était
sorti de très très vite et d'un peu
nulle part pour empêcher le candidat des
républicains en tout cas à date c'est
sûr qu'on peut être tenté de se dire que
l'élection ait joué maintenant des
quelques petits rappels en tant que
sondeurs le l'humilité la modestie
m'oblige à repréciser qu'un sondage que
les sondages ne sont que des mesures à
un instant t et ne soit absolument pas
prédictifs donc ça tu avances du
candidat macron peut-elle se réduire à
la faveur notamment de son entrée en
campagne dans l'arène politique s'il
descend bien dans l'arène politique et
c'est ce que demandent ses opposants que
ça s'arrête une certaine forme
d'inconnue en tout cas depuis cette
première depuis cette déclaration
officielle d'entrée en campagne de la
fin de semaine dernière emmanuel macron
reste sur une tendance où ils engrangent
des points parce que pour deux raisons
je vais faire très vite la première
s'est lui fait drapeau c'est que quand
vous avez un temps de crise extrêmement
importants comme celui que nous vivons
et bien il y a un effet capitale du nord
un effet drapeau qui fait que le
président de la république actuel
finalement fait
quand on dire fédère autour de lui de
fait et puis il ya en comment dire en
contraste le fait que face à lui il n'a
que des prétendants qui soit n'ont pas
été aux responsabilités évidemment mais
soit en tout cas 10 éprouve des
difficultés à faire entendre un autre
son de cloche et à proposer finalement
une solution alternative que ce soit un
projet politique électorale ou tout
simplement d'incarner un dirigeant
achètent des armes est convenable jean
philippe dayraut dans votre dernière
vague du du running ifop emmanuel macron
est à 30% c'est ça
tout à fait 30% des intentions de vote
il était déjà à environ un quart environ
25% depuis le depuis le début de la
campagne mais là on tutoie de nouveau
sommet pour le pour le président sortant
il ya un malin ce marine la semaine à
celle qu'ils auraient prévu il ya
quelques mois il est suivi de marine le
pen à 18% c'est ça puis suivent valérie
pécresse eric zemmour à 13h30
exactement et emmanuel macron en tout
cas dans les intentions de vote devant
ce sa première concurrente marine le pen
de 12 points 30% des intentions de vote
versus 18 et le reste de la droite est
relativement marginalisés avec valérie
pécresse sa candidature qui s'affaiblit
encore pour tomber à 13 % aujourd'hui
eric zemmour qui a dégringolé voilà
pendant qu emmanuel macron bonté à la
faveur de la crise en ukraine le les
intentions de vote en faveur d'eric
zemmour ont elles dégringolé il le
termine entre guillemets aujourd'hui à
12 5% des intentions de vote alors je le
disais tout à l'heure on connaît depuis
ce midi la liste officielle des
candidats y en aura 12 4 hommes quatre
femmes par druitt bon on n'est pas
encore à la verse douce et comme en 1974
comme en 2007 ces quatre de moins qu'en
2002 mais c'était en tout cas une très
très grosse une très très grosse session
présidentielle j'allais dire jean yves
camus est ce qu'on a déjà connu une
élection présidentielle avec autant de
représentants données droite ou de la
droite extrême
alors on a connu effectivement
l'élection présidentielle
ou jean marie le pen et bruno mégret
s'affrontaient et d'ailleurs c'est très
intéressant de voir qu'au second tour de
la présidentielle de 2002 jean marie le
pen fait son score du premier tour plus
les voix de bruno mégret plus quelques
dizaines de milliers autrement dit la
jonction des deux électorats malgré la
scission extrêmement turbulente de fin
1998 je suis pas persuadé que les choses
se passent de la même manière
[Musique]
eric zemmour il y aura il y aura
nécessairement reports de voix ceci
étant je suis pas persuadé qu'il
atteigne ce pourcentage quasi intégrale
avec sa direction vous avez des
surprises dans ses douze candidats
non je pense que c'est bien moi je
trouve ça bien qu'ils aient beaucoup de
candidats que toutes les sensibilités
soient représentés ceci dit ça montre à
un morcellement du paysage politique qui
est peut-être conforme aussi aux
fractures françaises un pays extrêmement
morcelé pour répondre à votre question
précédente je dirais que la singularité
c'est quand même que ce minsk en
national n'a peut-être jamais été aussi
haut jean yves camus évoqué jean marie
le pen bruno mégret âge pas sûr qu on
puisse les classes est tout à fait dans
la même famille politique qui eric
zemmour et marine le pen mais en tout
cas il faisait à eux deux même pas 20 %
je crois parce que bruno mégret faisait
un score très faible là on est autour de
30 % dès le premier tour si on ajoute
quelqu'un comme nicolas dupont aignan ça
fait encore un peu plus donc ça ça dit à
quel point c c voilà ces idées ont
progressé surtout elles sont
majoritaires à droite aujourd'hui
puisque l air si on en croit les
sondages seraient voués à connaître un
peu le même thème le même destin que le
parti socialiste alors revenons en
maintenant la campagne des macros en
commençant par deux petites phrases
qu'il a prononcées ce matin c'était rue
du rocher dans son quartier général de
campagne devant devant ses fidèles il
est dit la campagne je ne veux pas
l'éluder et puis il a dit aussi je serai
président en tant que je dois et je
serai candidat autant que je peux cdu et
en même temps tout craché mais en
gironde qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça
veut dire qu'il entend il entend bien
qu'un des axes principaux de ses
adversaires va être de dire que qui
laisse qu'un mode cette campagne qui le
refusent le débat qu'il refuse
l'obstacle et c'est le cas et que hic
jusqu'ici c'est difficile à dire parce
qu'il n'était pas candidat mais mais le
fait est que le contexte international
fait que ça s'y prête il a avant de de
réunir ses troupes ce matin envoyer le
message de papa des fusions jédir c'est
un candidat en période de guerre
c'est un président candidat en période
de guerre ça veut dire qu'on l'aura pas
de meeting samedi à coeur et des tirs
qui n'ont pas sont visiblement
l'intention de tout cas de les
multiplier voire même d'en organiser
aucun ça veut dire qu'il y aura quelques
confrontations avec des journalistes
mais globalement on est plutôt dans la
confrontation directe type grand débat
comme à l'image de ce qui va vivre ce
soir à poissy où là on aura 200 300
citoyens en les
îles voisines rien entendu trier comme
comme il comme il le faut donc on est là
donc ça veut dire qu'ils ont ils
semblent avoir entendu ça mais qu' il a
prévu la parade et qui est une autre
façon de débattre sans débattre mais il
a raison pour quelle raison il devrait
descendre dans l'arène si on leur
annonce place de son côté quelles sont
les raisons de dalé comme de 10 est un
sas guérini affronter les chausse
trappes c'est comme ça qu'il y avait les
débats avec potentiel de premier tour
avec ses adversaires aucune mais
peut-être parce que s'il n'y a pas de
confrontation de projets avant et on a
une après l'élection
avant
quand même la possibilité pour que cette
absence de débat qui est compréhensible
compte tenu du contexte international
soit mal ressenti par une partie de la
population
jean-philippe dubrulle
la situation internationale de serre si
vous nous dites décriviez tout à l'heure
ce set emmanuel macron occupé par
évidemment la guerre en ukraine c'est
une situation quoi de père de la nation
de chef de guerre même si la france
n'est pas très jeune
tout à fait c'est l'effet c'est l'effet
drapeau qu'on évoque depuis un certain
nombre de jours ce finalement des choses
qu'on a déjà vécu je rappelle ce n'était
pas des intentions de vote mais si on
prend les cotes de popularité des
présidents en exercice faut se rappeler
que entre avant et après les attentats
de janvier 2015 la cote de popularité de
françois hollande grimpé de 10 points
entre à vendre avant et après la non du
confinement en 2020 la cote de
popularité du président de la république
emmanuel macron grimpé aussi d'environ
10 points donc on voit qu'en temps de
crise où le rassemblement autour de la
figure du chef de l'état semble
nécessaire il y à il ya une prime en
fait au chef de l'état actuel et ça se
vérifie encore une fois dans le cadre de
cette campagne tout à fait inédite à
beaucoup d'égards mais le principal
étant la survenance de cette guerre en
pleine campagne électorale et alors que
le candidat sortant ne s'est justement
pas encore déclaré candidat en tout cas
oui d'après les sondages d'intentions de
vote ce que l'on voit c'est que c'est
que ce conflit sert les intentions de
vote en faveur des manuels mâcon dans un
double contexte ascension le fait que
plus on se rapproche de l'échéance plus
les gens nous disent qu'ils vont voter
et donc on a cette rentrée progressive
de nouveaux électeurs dans le jeu qui ne
et en et en même temps emmanuel macron
qui monte dans les intentions donc ça
veut bien dire qu'il ya un mouvement
réel de convergence en faveur d'
emmanuel macron et dans un contexte
alexandre alexandre le vecchio le le
disait bien dans un contexte d'offre
politique extrêmement fragmentée où
hormis marine le pen qui à 18% des
intentions de vote rendez vous compte
vous avez jean luc mélenchon en eau et
demi eric zemmour à nos ennemis et
valérie pécresse à xiii vous avez trois
prétendants qui sont à peine un point
d'écart c'est c'est du jamais vu sous la
vème république est très loin de la
qualification alexandre a vécu la guerre
en ukraine en disait belleserre d'une
certaine façon et mano mâcon elle a
percuté en tout cas l'agenda et la
campagne de tous ses rivaux comment vous
expliquez qu'il n'ait rien vu venir
sirigu
parce que personne n'a rien vu venir y
compris emmanuel macron qui était au
téléphone avec poutine et qui nous
attendent a annoncé une grande réunion
avec bayonne la veille je pense que oui
sans doute ni les médias d'ailleurs
beaucoup ont sous-estimé la menace que
représentait vladimir vladimir poutine
avec des conséquences ceci étant dit
pour rappel que sa plus importante pour
certains candidats pour d'autres parce
que certains avaient affiché une
certaine complaisance vis-à-vis de de
vladimir poutine et je pense qu'il a
perdu des points à ce moment là parce
qu'il est resté trop dans une halle été
rattrapé par le chroniqueur il a fait
des grandes analyses géopolitiques qui
n'était d'ailleurs pas forcément
inintéressante mais on était dans le
temps de l'émotion et dans une campagne
un candidat voilà doit doit tenir compte
de ça tenir compte des inquiétudes
profondes des français et là ça a été
effectivement je crois un tournant de
cette campagne mais il peut y en avoir
d'autres et tout à l'heure vous me
demandiez si emmanuel macron avait déjà
gagné j'ai répondu que oui à priori oui
mais il peut y avoir d'autres
rebondissements liés à la guerre on ne
sait jamais hein catastrophes
économiques qui peuvent encore voilà
bouleversé en partie au moins la demi
alexandre de lecture disait que tous ont
été rattrapés par par cette guerre en
ukraine et par leurs positions pro russe
tous n'ont pas forcément le même prix on
a l'impression de marine le pen s'en
sort plutôt mieux aucun d'eric zemmour
par exemple in le pen s'en sort mieux
parce qu'elle a une capacité à changer
de pied sur un certain nombre de sujets
fondamentaux qui est assez éprouvée
rappelez vous après 2017 sur l'union
européenne sur la sortie de l'euro elle
sait faire des biens culpin elle l'a
fait encore récemment sur un autre sujet
qui ont totalement mineurs qui est la
question de l'interdiction de la double
nationalité
je veut interdire lité c'était la
doctrine jusqu'à jusqu'à aujourd'hui
enfin j'étais il ya quelques semaines et
puis subitement il dit je me suis aperçu
qu'en fait il y avait un certain nombre
de cas où on ne pouvait pas se défaire
d'une de ces nationalités donc du coup
je change de pied elle l'a fait
relativement rapidement c'est un
exercice qui lui est assez coutumier je
crois qu'elle a réalisé aussi quelque
chose de fondamental c'est que on peut
effectivement
gloser sur l'otan son extension est ce
que c'est bien est-ce que c'est pas bien
dire oui mais toutes les responsabilités
sont pas du côté de la dîmière poutine
mais à un moment donné quand on a une
guerre d'agression quand on a quelque
chose qui s'apparente à au fait de
vouloir phagocyter un pays indépendant
et reconnu on peut plus dire ça on doit
être dans le manichéen on doit être dans
la déclaration d'intention disant voilà
cette guerre est une faute et la
responsabilité en incombe à la russie
marie le pen n'a fait travailler elle a
tout de suite été ravie par dix il faut
accueillir les réfugiés ukrainien et
risée mois après une semaine eric
zemmour s'est on
touche là à la limite du journaliste que
chroniqueur pas encore tout à fait
expérimenter et pas il a un peu des
sorties comme ça irisé mot pas tout à
fait contrôler et ensuite ils paient ni
mais quelques jours à revenir à
clarifier son propos et en l'occurrence
la nouvelle volte-face d'hier sur
l'accueil des réfugiés ukrainien à un
moment ça commence à se voir en fait ce
changement permanent de substances ça se
voit pas ce qu'il y avait un programme à
la base il y en a dont on connaît pas le
programme ces manuels mais les gros
score par là aujourd'hui c'est emmanuel
macron dont on connaît toujours pas le
programme il a appelé ce matin ses
fidèles à défendre le bilan du
quinquennat et notamment des bons
chiffres estime-t-il du chômage et c'est
vrai que c'est plus facile à défendre le
bilan parce que le projet le programme
on ne sait pas encore grand chose va
d'ailleurs faire le point sur cette
question avec steve steve jourdain qu'on
a
bonsoir monsieur bonsoir style oui donc
ce programme qui se fait un peu désirer
un pour l'instant le chef de l'état est
mobilisé par la guerre en ukraine pour
pas dire happé par cette guerre en
ukraine difficile dans ces conditions
évidemment de promettre le retour ou
d'annoncés ces jours heureux dont on
parle parfois dans cette campagne cette
déclaration de candidature sobre
succincte trois pages dans une lettre
publiée vendredi dans la presse
quotidienne régionale sur le fond pas
grand chose le disruptif comme on dit il
n'ya pas d'indépendance en force
économique il nous faudra donc
travailler plus et poursuivre la baisse
des impôts pesant sur le travail et la
production voilà ce qu'écrit emmanuel
macron entendez par là qu'il faudra
passer par cette réforme des retraites
promises est engagée par emmanuel macron
réformes avortées évidemment à cause de
la crise sanitaire à la manuelle mâcon
qui a aussi promis de faire de la france
une grande nation écologique et de
réduire notre dépendance aux énergies
fossiles m mais pour les détails on va
devoir encore attendre un peu parce que
pour l'instant c'est plus des idées
poser que des mesures c'est assez pour
l'instant c'est des grandes lignes
emmanuel macron candidat fait un passage
vous l'avez dit aujourd'hui par son qg
de campagne il a assuré qu' bien qu'ils
ne voulaient pas éluder la campagne il a
lancé plusieurs grands chantiers trois
grands axes ont été annoncés école santé
institutions des annonces pour l'instant
mais pas grand chose de très précis au
qg de campagne il y avait plusieurs
barons locaux comme hubert falco le
maire de toulon eq c'est l'air il nous
raconte la visite du président candidat
c'était au micro de marion delpech
écouter le plus abordé son programme sur
le projet il a donné des priorités aidé
à parler
du contexte international et il a parlé
de la france de se rassembler surtout se
rassembler plus que jamais il a parlé de
l'économie il a parlé de l'école il a
parlé
durand d'âge jeune candidat déterminé un
président soucieux de l'intérêt de la
france voilà des grandes lignes donc
mais pour l'instant pas de détails très
précis sur ce programme il y aura à coup
sûr un gros volet énergie et nucléaire
avec construction annoncée de ces 6 p r
il est aussi un volet plus régaliens
même si dans la lettre adressée aux
français par exemple pas un mot sur
l'immigration quand même c'est à
signaler et puis ce matin le patron en
marche vous l'avez signalé tout à
l'heure ça ni cela ce gars il me disait
qu un programme politique détaillé
verrait le jour dans les semaines qui
viennent va falloir faire vite le
premier tour c'est dans un peu plus d'un
mois matin exactement 34 jours mais
angers remonte au fond est ce que c'est
si important pour le maquereau d'avoir
un catalogue de mesures de propositions
pour pour pour tous les écrits qu'on a
signalé tout à l'heure oui
c'est quand même un 6/6 veut s'il veut
véritablement mais c'est penser qu'il
est un candidat entre guillemets comme
les autres et qui ne profitent pas
uniquement de la la rampe de lancement
du contexte actuel oui c'est important
d'avoir un d'avoir un programme et 2 et
2 et de tenir compte des cinq années
écoulées et ça ça s'appelle pilot
d'ailleurs un bilan mais je veux dire de
concevreux on dit souvent qu'on ne sait
pas et bien sûr un bilan est quand on
discute avec et avec les légendes la
majorité ils disent aussi mais regardez
quand obama s'est représenté camp merkel
s'est représenté qui se souvient des
propositions qu'ils ont fait c'était par
la question au fond c'est juste la
personnalité qui qui comptait selon une
d'ailleurs quand françois mitterrand
sont représentés c'était sur le slogan
la france unie avait pas vraiment de
deux programmes se lèvent le camp ça a
été un peu plus au fait mais oui c'était
une autre époque
aussi mais en réalité je sais pas s'il
faut un programme détaillé et chiffré
moi j ai jamais cru même en cas de
première élection par contre il faut une
vision et on sait plus très bien quelle
est la vision des manuels macro il ya
cinq ans c'était clairement le président
de la mondialisation heureuse il nous
parlait du nouveau monde il nous parlait
de la start up nation là quand j'ai lu
ça ça l'est on sent que il a compris
qu'on était dans le tragique et qu'on
pouvait plus tenir ce type de discours
là reste à savoir quel va être on a
compris qu'il voulait un état fort
finalement il se range
du côté des souverainistes sur beaucoup
de choses je trouve vous parler du
nucléaire quelqu'un qui était au
contrôle nucléaire jusqu'il ya peu qui a
fermé fessenheim et qui aujourd'hui va
construire des ep acx par contre il ya
une ambiguïté sur la méthode par exemple
quand il parle d'une france qui protège
d'unités contre les déserts médicaux et
c est ce qui va le faire avec un peu de
protectionnisme avec le retour des
dassault ou est-ce qu'il va le faire
tentez rester aussi fervent européens
qu'ils l'étaient et continuer avec
l'idée d'une souveraineté européenne ça
on sait pas ça va être intéressant de
voir s'il a évolué complètement sur
cette question là qui est peut-être le
vrai clivage aujourd'hui entre des gens
qui sont propres aux mondialisation et
et ceux qui sont plus pour de la
protection de la promesse du de la
souveraineté il a bougé pas mal de
curseur quand même les flammes il
promettait la révolution n'est plus
franchement dans la révolution est ce
qu'il y ait ce qui prend un risque en
transformant cette élection en stop ou
encore
écoutez je pense que d'abord les
électeurs ne sont pas nécessairement
sensible au catalogue de propositions et
au détail des programmes moi j'ai
toujours cru que si vous interrogez et
français sur connaissez-vous littell
numéro 37 demain chaque candidat ça ne
marche pas ils ne peuvent pas vous
répondre dans game annuel mâcon mais
c'est aussi la logique des institutions
de la vème république
il joue sur le fait que nos institutions
donne une prime à celui effectivement et
le capitaine du navire surtout par
surtout par gros temps est-ce que ça va
suffire non je pense qu'il va falloir
effectivement qu'il rentre dans le dur
il ya des sujets comme l'immigration sur
lesquels je crois qu'il n'a pas intérêt
à aller trop dent dure il a intérêt à
laisser chat précisément à ceux qui en
font fondre comme elle et pardon je vous
interromps mais qui ne figure plus parmi
les priorités des français de
l'immigration gentil quand on regarde
aujourd'hui c'est social aujourd'hui
qu'ils font
et c'est ce que marine le pen d'ailleurs
assez bien compris je trouve par rapport
à eric zemmour alors pendant ce temps-là
ses rivaux ne s'avouent pas vaincus 1 l
et issac repas vous revenez sur l'autre
événement politique du lancement en
campagne c'est le ralliement de marion
maréchal à eric zemmour est ce que vous
avez vu à la télévision cet événement
oui non danse mime et ben voilà c'est
quand même le gros défaut de cet
évènement c'est-à-dire que quand l'image
n'est pas télédiffusés alors certaines
et sur internet sur les plateformes ok
mais on rate quand même un gros de la
cible qui va voter justement qui ne
s'abstient pas c'est à dire les
retraités et d'autres d'autres
catégories qu'ils sont moins captif du
numérique mais bon ça c'était le détail
c'est un événement parce que marion
maréchal c'est une marque elle a retiré
le nom le pen mais c'est la marque le
pen marion maréchal donc bien sûr c'est
un événement mais il arrive trop tard je
vais vous expliquer pourquoi mais on va
d'abord regarder un extrait de son
discours c'était sur la scène du zénith
à toulon hyères
je suis absolument convaincu qu'eric
zemmour est le mieux placé dans cette
élection présidentielle
en anton rocco vous avez déjà commencé à
réaliser beaucoup de pourquoi je plaide
depuis desana idée construire cette
grande union à droite tuez les crues ci
a fait revivre chaque jour en attirant
dans son sillage des personnalités
issues de l ère du rnd d'ailleurs j'en
avais fait et vous l'avez affaire
alors est-ce qu'il suffit de marteler de
scander cette union de la droite et ne
me semble pas je pense qu'il est temps
de la réaliser a maintenant presque un
mois du premier tour de la
présidentielle or dans les prises de
guerre d'eric zemmour il y à guillaume
pelletier qu'il y ait des républicains
ce n'est quand même pas la star et puis
son côté girouette dévalorise quand même
voilà son ralliement à eric léser mots
pour le moment eric zemmour échoue il
n'a aucune star des républicains à ses
côtés et là où elle va et d eric zemmour
si vous voulez bien sûr qu'elle
dépossède marine le pen des poussettes
sa tente directement mais elle apporte
quelque chose quand même marion maréchal
la touche féminine et ce n'est pas du
tout anecdotique c'est à dire qu'il est
quand même taxé et à raison de misogyne
parce qu'il ya ces écrits qui sont là
eric zemmour et donc elles apportent la
touche féminine dans sa candidature mais
pour vous ça vient trop tard pour lui
c'est beaucoup trop tard et pourquoi
parce que depuis octobre on les a vus
tous les deux à budapest depuis deux
mois d'octobre on sait qu'elle va
probablement très certainement sûrement
se rallièrent exe moore donc au mot le
moment où ça arrive on l'a tellement
entendu c'est ça tellement fuite et que
l'effet surprise fait pschitt c'est
normal avec tout si vous avancez à votre
cousine que vous arrivez dans trois mois
le jour où vous arrivez vous allez voir
et va être moins surprise bon bah ça
fait comme ça avec comme avec marion
maréchal donc est peut-être qu'elle a ça
c'est une hypothèse elle a peut-être
aussi laisser le temps à s'attendre tout
de même de préparer une riposte en tout
cas elle joue là prêt marion maréchal
elle joue justement cette recomposition
de la droite vous pariez elle joue
législatives elle a déjà annoncé qu'elle
aurait sa petite composition formation
politique qu'elle voudra des sièges
évidemment donc à tous ou boulets
jean yves camus est ce que c'est ce que
les américains appellent un kane
challenger est ce que ça peut changer
quelque chose à campagne d'eric zemmour
on ce ralliement d'un mignon je suis pas
persuadé d'abord parce que c'est tardif
ensuite parce que là la vraie période
intéressante ça va être celle qui sépare
le soir du premier tour des élections
législatives parce que c'est là
véritablement que six en tout cas
valérie pécresse ferme les scores
certains airs se diront bon c'est
peut-être le moment de changer de
boutique quand même pour l'instant
personne n'a intérêt s'il agit en sujet
rationnelle de risque et comme guillaume
pelletier de rater une réélection qui
pourrait être acquis sous la bannière
heller on se présente en candidat de
reconquête ensuite c'est ce que c'est
vraiment un game seigneur non parce que
lui ont des droits vision
c'est je peux pas chiffré les millions
mais on peut apparemment chiffrer le
nombre d'investiture qui est la demande
et c'est beaucoup et à un moment donné
ma question c'est est-ce qu'un parti
aussi personnalisé que reconquête avec
le le talent d'eric zemmour son talent
de polémiste et son talent d'homme de
scène on ne peut pas lui dénier comment
ça va cohabiter avec marion maréchal et
scanne la place pour deux dans le
casting comment la sphère l'osmose des
gens qui sont arrivés parmi les premiers
à reconquête et des quelques dizaines de
candidats que marion maréchal va faire
investir et qui vont quand même piquer
la place à un moment donné de quelqu'un
qui disait préfet de candidats dans une
circo et qui finalement ne le sera pas
compliqué on dans l'entourage de
des de jean marie le pen marie le pen et
de tous ces gens qui connaissent de
l'intérieur la machine
ils ont visiblement beaucoup observé les
visages hier de l'entourage d'eric
zemmour et quand vous regardiez de
sourire un peu crispé c'est comme ça
qu'on me l'a décrit de sarah knafo par
exemple on les sent pas extrêmement
serein sur les intentions de marion
maréchal-le pen marion maréchal est à la
fois
et la collaboratrice la plus proche de
derry zemmour les intentions de marion
maréchal sont assez claires marion
marché n'est pas destiné à être
éternellement un numéro deux et elle
vient pas à bure et les sandwichs comme
cam comme dit l'autre donc il ya quand
même quelque chose d'un peu plus
complexe que justin game challenger
quelqu'un qui vient en soutien
effectivement laetitia lisez tard en
plus avec cendrillon pourquoi il va et
pourquoi maintenant
ali va effectivement pour pour jouer le
3e tournoi je suis pas persuadé qu'elle
veut le veuille absolument le premier
rôle que ce qui est souvent entendu dire
que ce appelons le pen elle avait besoin
peut-être d'être ministre d'un
gouvernement de droite avec une
personnalité plus plus plus classiques
comme sas de décontamination d'une
certaine manière avant peut-être tel de
se lancer dans la cale dans la campagne
présidentielle
voilà parce qu'elle est jeune mais de
toute manière je suis pas persuadé que
eric zemmour s'accroche forcément au
rôle de leader je suis pas sûr que ce
soit marion maréchal non plus mais je
crois que le rôle historique que se
donne eric zemmour était de faire
exploser et le rassemblement national et
l'élève s'il y arrive il aura rempli
l'objectif qu'ils s'étaient qui s'était
fixé maintenant sur marion maréchal
s'est il ya une interview qu'il faudrait
relire qui était très intéressante alain
correct il avait débattu tous les deux
avant la convention de la droite et
c'était intéressant parce qu'il n'avait
pas du tout la même stratégie marion
maréchal était pour une
l'union des droites justement et à
l'époque eric zemmour était pas sur sa
stratégie qu'on connaît aujourd'hui il
disait faut faire du populisme face au
mondialisme macro nist le clivage droite
gauche est totalement balayé allons
chercher les classes populaires et les
classes moyennes ou aisées patriotes et
on voit qu'il est revenue à l'union des
droites et c'est peut-être ça qui va lui
manquer pour être devant marine même
marine le pen puisque marine le pen a
conservé son électorat populaire est ce
qui explique qu'elles aient calé devant
dans les sondages en conséquence la lui
a du mal à convaincre l'électorat
populaire notamment jean yves camus est
ce que ça fait pas forcément de 2,2 bien
eric zemmour mais est-ce que ça fait du
mal à marine le pen ce transfert ce
ralliement
non je pense pas parce que comme vous
venez de le dire c'était quand même
quelque chose d'assez prévisible ah
c'est pas c'est pas un immense scoop
voilà donc les faits quand même assez
assez modérée non moi je ne pense pas
que ce soit un booster
après je suis effectivement d'accord le
rôle d'eric zemmour c'est plus tôt pour
parler le langage de la nouvelle droite
le rôle d'éveilleurs le rôle de
quelqu'un qui effectivement fait sortir
des sujets un moment donné qui éveille
les consciences à quelque chose et je
pense que dans quelques années dans
quelques temps sans doute il acceptera
de passer la main pensent ils ont que
l'essentiel du travail est fait c'est à
ce moment là avec marianne mareschal
pourra véritablement de capitaliser sur
tout ce qu'il a fait jusqu'ici mais ont
vu de la présidentielle mais je pense
pas que ça puisse sont les moufles
j'assiste marion maréchal ou ou un autre
ou une autre je suis pas persuadé
qu'elles veulent assumer ce rôle de
leader et tout lui des cirés suisses ont
parlé c'est aussi d'arrimer des gens
comme david lisnard comme laurent
wauquiez com
je pense que je pense que c'est pas
encore fait mais co2 hier soir au
deuxième tour il peut y avoir des déçus
reprise ou comme eric ciotti je vois mal
ces gens-là cohabiter avec une ligne p
créée 6 on voit bien qu'ils font pas
campagne arrive beaucoup d'enthousiaste
alors je sais pas s'ils rejoindront
reconquête mais en tout cas je pense que
l air va sortir fractionné encore une
fois de cette de cette campagne
présidentielle et que certains ont
vocation à rejoindre emmanuel macron
partie parce qu'ils partagent la même
ligne politique et d'autres à incarner
une droite plus identitaire plus
souverainiste peut-être même plus
sociale par un actionnaire ou de
disparaître quand on a connu pour le
parti socialiste
en tout cas le parti socialiste existe
encore il a il a plu il a plu beaucoup
de il a plu beaucoup de points peut-être
refaire quelque chose qui s'appellera
plus et l'air mais en tout cas il y aura
clairement des gens qui rêvent qu'ils
seront plus conservateur et d'autres qui
auront vocation à carrément rejoindre là
la majorité qui va qui va s'organiser
peut-être au tour d'edouard philippe qui
arrive en éclaireur lui aussi très
rapidement qu'est-ce qui a fait que la
droite bascule comme ça pourquoi tout
soudainement le corps dans son exposé le
fait que son union est artificielle
c'est à dire qu'au fond il y a depuis
très longtemps au moins deux lignes pour
ne pas dire 3 qui cohabitent au sein de
ce qui est aujourd'hui et l'herbe et
c'était vrai ou paravent au sein de
l'ump et dont les fondamentaux sont pas
les mêmes si vous êtes nationaliste
populiste souverainistes ou si vous êtes
un pro européen libéral
aujourd'hui vous avez un moment donné
des choix binaire affaire et se sont pas
les mêmes mais en l'air pour conclure
est-ce que l'explosion de l'échiquier
politique qui avait réalisé madame
accroc en 2017 est irréversible et il
semble se confirmer qu'effectivement
elle va se elle va se renforcer
et d'abord évidemment le score de 2-2
wehrli pécresse va être 20 être
intéressant à observer mais mais j'irai
quand on parlait de marion maréchal qui
clairement est là pour ramener à eric
zemmour le les électeurs d'eric ciotti
on va dire perdu du dernier congrès la
partie la plus laide plus la plus à
droite la plus conservatrice clairement
c'est celle encore une fois la preuve
que ce cette droite républicaine est
amené à exploser et que l'explosion qui
est encore en rond qui se poursuit là
avec les nouveaux ralliements à emmanuel
macron va se poursuivre il ya quid de l
air quid de d'edouard philippe dans tout
ça effectivement qui va observer la
décomposition et il faire les comptes à
la fin c'est tout ça qui va qui va
dépendre de cette élection eh bien merci
à tous pour ce débat merci à vous
mélangez un bon rappel votre biographie
d'edouard philippe le ciu opposition
l'archipel ainsi jean-yves camus merci
alexandre ii vecchio et issa vaut rester
avec moi je file dubrulle lui nous a
quittés il nous avait annoncé qu'il
devait le faire un peu plus tôt